The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Well, hope
you had a good Thanksgiving.
So this is partly
review today, even.
Wednesday even more review.
Wednesday evening,
or Wednesday at 4
I'll be here for any questions.
And then the exam is
Thursday at 7:30 in Walker.
Top floor of Walker this
time, not the same 54-100.
OK, and then, no
lectures after that.
Holiday, whatever.
Yes.
Right, you get a
chance to do something.
Catch up with all
those other courses
that are being neglected
in favor of 18.085.
Right.
OK, so here's a bit
of review right away.
We really had four cases.
We started with Fourier series,
that was periodic functions.
And then discrete Fourier
series, also periodic in a way.
Because w^N was one.
So that we have N
numbers and then
we could repeat
them if we wanted.
So those are the
two that repeat.
This is the f(x),
this is all x, so that
would be the Fourier integral
that we did just last week.
Fourier integral transform.
And this was the--
Well, these are all,
this is the discrete
all the way.
So that's-- oh, you can
see these pair off, right?
The periodic function,
the 2pi periodic function
has Fourier
coefficients for all k,
so that's the pair
that we started with.
Section 4.1.
This sort of pairs, I don't
know whether to say with itself.
I mean, we start with N numbers
and we end with N numbers.
We have N numbers
in physical space.
And we have N numbers
in frequency space.
Right, so we call those,
so those went to c_0 up
to c_(N-1).
And this, all x, pair--
for the function,
paired off with itself.
Or with this went to F--
well maybe I used small f.
I guess I did in last week.
So that, and I called its
Fourier transform f hat of k,
all k.
So that's the pairing kind of
inside n-dimensional space,
with the Fourier matrix.
This is the pairing
of the formula for f,
and its similar
formula for f hat,
and these are the guys that
connect with each other.
OK, so that's what we know.
What we haven't done is
anything in two dimensions.
So I would like to
include that today.
I think my real
message about 2-D,
and I'm not going to
include it on the exam,
but you might wonder, OK, can
I have a function of x and y?
And will the whole setup work?
And the answer is yes.
So really, my message is not
to be afraid in any way of 2-D.
It's just the same formulas
with x,y or two indices, k,l.
Yeah.
You'll see that.
OK, now for the new part.
What's a convolution equation?
That's my word for
an equation where
instead of doing a
convolution and finding
the right-hand
side, instead we're
given the right-hand side.
And the unknown is
in the convolution.
So let me write examples
of convolution equation.
Every one of these would
allow a convolution.
So the convolution
equation would
be something the integral
of F(t) u, for the unknown,
at x-t, is-- Oh no, sorry.
F will be the right-hand side.
F of, well, can I--
Yeah, better if I put it
on the right-hand side.
Wouldn't want to call
it the right-hand side.
So this would be some, shall
I call it often K for kernel
is sometimes the word.
So what I'm saying is
equations come this way.
This is really K
convolved with u.
Equals F. You see, the only
novelty is the unknown is here.
So that's why the word
deconvolution is up there.
Because that's
what we have to do.
We have to undo the convolution,
this unknown function
is convolved with a known, K is
known, some known kernel that
tells us the point
spread of the telescope
or whatever we're doing.
And gives us the output
that we're looking at.
And then we have
to find the input.
OK, can I write down the similar
equations for the other three
here?
And then we'll just
think how would we find
u, how would we solve them?
So the equation here
might be that some kernel
circle convolved with
the unknown u is some y.
These are now vectors.
This is known.
And those, the N components
of u, are unknown.
OK, so that would be
the same problem here.
What would be here?
Same thing.
Now the integral will go
from-- The only difference is
the integral will go from
minus infinity to infinity,
K(t)u(x-t) dt equal f(x).
And finally regular convolution.
What am I going to call it?
K would be a sequence,
maybe I should call it a,
known, convolved with u,
unknown, is some c, known.
Yeah.
So those would be
four equations.
You might say, wait
a minute, where
is Professor Strang come
up with these problems
at the last week of the course.
But, these are exactly
the type of problems
that we know and love.
These come from
constant-coefficient,
time-invariant, shift-invariant
linear problems.
LTI, linear time-invariant.
And my lecture Wednesday,
just before Thanksgiving, took
a differential equation
for u and found,
and put it in this form.
I'll come back to that.
So suddenly we're
seeing, I mean,
we're actually seeing
some new things
but also it includes
all the old ones.
These are all of the best
problems in the world.
These linear
constant-coefficient problems.
Time invariant, of
any of these types.
This one was an
integral from minus pi
to pi, where this
one went all the way.
So this is not brand new stuff.
But it sort of looks new.
And now the question is, so my
immediate question is, before
doing any example, how would
you solve such an equation.
And I saw on old exams,
some of this sort
for example, let me
focus on this one.
Let me, instead of
K there, I'm not
used to using K for a
vector, I'm used to,
well maybe I'll use c.
For the vector there.
So this is n
equations, n unknowns.
Oops, capital N
is our usual here.
For the number.
N u, N unknown u's.
It's a matrix equation
with a circulant matrix.
So all these equations are
sort of the special best kind.
Because they're convolutions.
And now tell me the main point.
How do we solve
equations like this?
How do we do a deconvolution,
so the unknown is convolved
with c here, it's convolved
with K, it's convolved with a,
how do we deconvolve
it to get u by itself?
So what's the central idea here?
Central idea: go
into frequency space.
Use the convolution rule.
In frequency space,
where these transform,
we're looking at multiplication.
And multiplication, we can undo.
We can de-multiply.
De-multiply is just a big
word for divide, right?
So that's the point.
Get into that space.
That's what we've been
doing all the time.
I better get one example,
the example from the problem
Wednesday, just up here.
Just so you see it.
This won't look like a
convolution equation,
but do you remember that it
was -u'' plus a squared u equal
some f(x)?
So that's a constant, it's
certainly constant-coefficient,
linear, time-invariant.
Right, OK.
And how did we solve that?
We took Fourier transforms.
So this was the
second derivative,
the Fourier transform.
What is the rule for the
Fourier transform of derivative?
Every derivative brings
down an ik in the transform.
So we get ik twice.
So it's k squared. i squared
cancels the minus one.
So that's the transform of -u''.
This is the transform of
ordinary a squared u, just
a squared.
And this is f hat.
So we've got into
frequency space.
Where we are just
seeing a multiplication,
k squared plus a squared, u
hat, of-- this is u hat of k,
equals f hat of k, right?
Oh well, sorry we were-- Yeah,
that's right. f hat of k,
right.
So we're in frequency
space, where we just
see a multiplication.
So again, this is now we
just demultiply, just divide.
And then we have the answer,
but we have its transform.
And then we have
to transform back.
So we have to do the Fourier
transform to get to the,
I'll say the inverse
Fourier transform.
To get back to u(x), the answer.
That's the model.
And that's maybe the
one that we've seen,
now we're able to think
about all these four topics.
Right.
OK, so what was the key idea?
Get into frequency
space and then it's
just a, the equation is
just a multiplication,
so the solution is
just a division.
So can I do that now with
these four examples, just see.
So this is like bring
the pieces together.
OK, and deconvolution is
a very key thing to do.
OK, so I'll take
all four of those
and bring them into
frequency space.
So this will be
maybe, you'll let
me use K hat of, oh, K hat
of k that's not too good.
Well, stuck with it.
What am I doing here?
In this 2pi periodic one?
That's the one I started
with, but now I've got,
I'm using hats and so on.
I didn't do that in Section 4.1.
What the heck am I going to,
what notation am I going to do?
And I really didn't do
convolution that much,
for functions.
So let me jump to here.
I'll come back.
It follows exactly
the same pattern.
So let me jump to this one.
OK, so I have a
convolution equation now.
This is one where you
could do this one.
This could appear on the quiz
because I can do all of it.
So what is this convolution?
OK.
I've got N equations,
N unknowns.
Let me write them
in matrix form,
just so you see it that way
too. c_0, c_1, c_2, c_3.
I'll make N equal four.
And then these are, this
convolution has c_0, c_2, c_1.
c_3, c_2, c_1, c_0.
This'll be c_3, c_3,
c_3, I'm writing down
all the right numbers
in the right places.
So that when I do
that multiplication
with the unknown,
[u 0, u 1,  u 2, u 3],
I get the right-hand, the
known right-hand side.
Maybe b would be
a little better.
Because we're more used
to b as as a known.
It's just an Ax=b problem,
or an Au=b problem.
It looks like a
convolution but now
it's just a matrix
multiplication.
So this is just
[b 0, b 1, b 2,  b 3].
OK.
That's our equation.
Special type of matrix.
Circulant matrix.
So this is just
literally the same
as c circularly convolved
with u equals b.
I just wrote it out
in matrix language.
So you could call MATLAB with
that matrix, and so one way
to answer it would be get
the inverse of the matrix.
But if it was
large, a better way
would be switch over
to frequency space.
Think, now.
What happens when I switch these
vectors to frequency space?
It becomes a multiplication.
So this becomes
a multiplication.
Now so c, I want the Fourier,
from the c's, what am I
going to-- So these are
all in the space where
it's a convolution.
What am I going to call it
where it's in the space where
it's a multiplication?
I just need three new names.
Maybe I'll use c
hat, u hat, and b hat
just because there's no
doubt in anybody's mind
that when you see
that hat, you've
gone into frequency space.
Now, what's the equation
in frequency space?
And then I'll do an example.
It's a multiplication,
but I don't usually
see a vector and nothing there.
What's the multiplication
in frequency space?
It's component by component.
c_0*u_0 equals b_0. c hat
1 u hat 1 equals b hat 1.
c hat 2 u hat 2 equals b hat 2.
And finally, c hat 3 u
hat 3 equals b hat 3.
And there might be, I don't
swear that there isn't, a 1/4
somewhere.
Right?
But the point is, we're
in frequency space now.
We just have a
component by component,
each component of c hat
times each component of u hat
gives us a component
of b hat; now we're
ready for a deconvolution;
just divide.
So now u hat,
obviously I don't have
to write all these,
b hat 0 over c hat 0.
Right?
I just do a division.
So on down to u hat 3 is b hat,
is the third component of b,
divided by the third
component of c.
OK, now don't forget here.
That in going from
here to here, I
had to figure out what
the c hats were, right?
I had to do the Fourier matrix,
or the inverse Fourier matrix
to go from c to c
hat, from b to b hat,
so everything got
Fourier transformed.
But the object was to
make the equation easy.
And of course, now we've
got four trivial equations
that we just solved that way.
Alright, let me see if I
can just pull this down
with some questions.
Here's a good question.
When is a circulant
matrix invertible?
When will this method work?
The circulant matrix could
fail to be invertible.
How would I know that?
If it's singular, and how
would I, if I proceed this way,
here I've got an answer.
But if it's singular
I'm not really
expecting to get an answer.
Let me lift the board a little.
So where would I get, oops,
have to stop this method.
In solving those four equations.
Where would I learn
that it's is singular?
What could go wrong in this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: That's right.
Always in math, the question
is are you dividing by zero.
So the question of whether
the matrix is singular,
is the same as the question
of whether c_0 hat,
c_01, c_02, and c_03-- sorry,
c_0 hat, c_1 hat, c_2 hat,
and c_3 hat, can't be zero.
That's, in fact, even better
those four numbers, those four
c hats, are actually the
eigenvalues of the matrix.
We've switched, what the Fourier
transform did, was switch over
to the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors.
And there, that's the whole
message of those guys is,
you follow each one separately.
Just the way we're doing here.
So this is the component of
the b in the four eigenvector
directions.
Those are the four eigenvalues,
and I have to divide by them.
You see, the idea is, like,
we've diagonalized the matrix.
We've had that
matrix, which is full.
And we take-- By taking the
Fourier transforms, that's
the same thing as as
putting in the eigenvectors,
switching the matrix to
this diagonal matrix, right?
Our problem has become,
like, the diagonalized form
is c_0 hat down to c_3 hat,
sitting on the diagonal.
All zeroes elsewhere.
That's when we switched, when
we did Fourier transform we
were switching to eigenvectors.
OK, so that's the message.
That the test for singularity is
the Fourier, the transform of c
hits zero.
Then we're in trouble.
Let me do an example you know.
OK here's, so finally now
we get a numerical example.
The example we really
know is this one, right?
As I start writing that,
you may say in your mind,
oh no not again.
But give it to me, one more
week with these matrices.
But it'll be the C matrix, so
it's going to be the circulant.
Recognize this?
And it's got those minus
ones in the corners, too.
OK, let's go back to day one.
Is that matrix invertible?
Yes or no.
Please, no.
Everybody knows that
matrix is not invertible.
And do you remember
what's in the null space?
Yes, what's the vector in the
null space of that matrix?
All ones.
Now, when I take,
just think now.
When I take Fourier
transform, that all ones is
going to transform to what?
It's going to
transform to the delta.
It'll transform to the one
that is like [1, 0, 0, 0].
Or maybe it's [4, 0, 0, 0].
But it's that, well, OK, now I'm
ready to take, so here's my c.
So what's my method now?
I'm going to do this method,
and I'm going to run into,
this thing is going to be zero.
Because that's the
eigenvalue that
goes with the [1, 1, 1, 1, 1]
column, the constant, the zero
frequency in frequency space.
You'll see it happen.
So let's take the Fourier
transform of that.
And then we would have
to take the Fourier
transform of the
right-hand side b, whatever
that happened to be.
But it's always the left side.
The singular or not matrix.
I believe we'll
be singular here.
So, OK, just remind me how do
I take transforms of this guy?
Gosh, we have to
be able to do that.
That's Section 4 point,
well, 4.3 isn't, yeah.
The DFT of that vector.
What do I get?
Yes.
How do I take the
DFT of a vector?
I multiply by the
Fourier matrix, right?
Yes.
So I have to multiply that
thing by the Fourier matrix.
So to get c hat, this was
big C for the matrix, little
c for the vector that goes
into it, into column zero.
And c hat for its transform.
OK, so now here comes the
Fourier matrix that we know, 1,
i, i^2, i^3; 1, i^2, i^4,
i^6; 1, i^3, i^6, and i^9.
So I want to transform that
c to get, to find out c hat.
OK, and what do I get up there?
What's the first component,
the zeroth component
I should say, when I take this
guy, this four, this vector
with four components
and I get back
four components, the
frequency components, what's
the first one?
Ones times this,
what am I getting?
Zero.
That's what I expected.
That tells me the matrix is
not going to be invertible.
Because in a different language,
I'm finding the eigenvalues
and that's one of them.
And if an eigenvalue
is zero, that
means the eigenvector is
getting knocked out completely.
And there's no way a c
inverse could recover
when that eigenvector is gone.
OK, let's do the other ones.
Two minus i, nothing.
What's the other one here?
Two, this is minus i, and
that's plus i, I think.
So I think it's just two.
Alright, this is 2 i squared,
can I write in some of these
just so I have a little,
i squared is minus one,
and i^4 is one, and
that's minus one.
So that's two plus one,
plus one, I think is four.
And then i^3 is the
same as minus i.
And i^9 is the same as plus i.
So I think I'm getting two
plus i, nothing, minus i: two.
So what's my claim?
My claim is that these
are the four eigenvalues,
that the Fourier-- Fourier
diagonalizes these problems.
That's what it comes to.
Fourier diagonalizes all
constant-coefficient,
shift-invariant,
linear problems.
And tells us here
are eigenvalues.
So [0, 2, 4, 2].
Would you like
to, how do I check
the eigenvalues of a matrix?
Let's just remember.
If I give you four numbers and
I say those are the eigenvalues,
and you look at that
matrix, what quick check
does everybody do?
Compute the?
The trace.
Add up the diagonal
of the matrix,
add up the proposed eigenvalues,
they had better be the same.
And they are.
I get eight both ways.
That doesn't mean, of course,
that these four numbers are
right, but I think they are.
Yeah, yeah.
So those added up to
eight, those numbers
added up to eight.
And yep.
And these are real.
They came out
real, and how did I
know that would happen
from the matrix?
What matrices am I certain
to get real eigenvalues for?
Symmetric.
Right.
Now, what about, I
heard the word positive.
Of course, that's the other
question I have to ask.
Is this matrix
positive definite?
OK, everybody, this
is the language
we've learned in 18.085.
Is that matrix positive
definite, yes or no?
No.
What is it?
It's positive semi-definite.
What does that tell
me about eigenvalues?
There, one is zero, that's why
it's not positive definite.
But the others are positive.
So that sure enough,
in other words,
what we've done here, for that
matrix that came on day one
and now we're seeing
it on day N-1 here.
We're we're seeing sort of in
a new way, because at that time
we didn't know these four
were the eigenvectors
of that matrix.
But they are.
And we're coming to
the same conclusion
we came to on day one.
That the matrix is
positive semi-definite
and that we know
its eigenvalues.
And we can,
actually, let me even
take it one more step, just
because this example is
so perfect.
Some right-hand sides we
could solve for, right?
If I have a matrix
that's singular.
Way, way back, even, I think
it was like a worked example
in Section 1.1, I could ask the
question when is Cx=b solvable.
Because there are some
right-hand sides that'll work.
Because if I just take
an x and multiply by C,
I'll get a right-hand
side that works.
But for which vectors,
right-hand sides b,
will my method work?
The ones that have...?
Yeah, the ones that have which?
What do I need with these
c's, c_0, c_1, c_2, and c_3,
for my solution to be possible.
I need b_0 hat.
Equals zero.
I need b_0 hat equals zero.
And then what does that say?
That means that the
b, the vector b,
has no constant term
in the Fourier series.
It means that the vector b is
orthogonal to the [1, 1, 1, 1],
eigenvector.
So this is like a subtle point
but just driving home the point
that what Fourier does is
diagonalize everything.
It diagonalizes all the
important problems of,
all the simplest problems,
of differential equations.
You know, I mean this is like
18.03 looked at from Fourier's
point of view.
OK, what more could I
do with that equation?
I think you really are seeing
all the good stuff here.
You're seeing the matrix.
We're recognizing
it as a circulant.
We're realizing that we could
take its Fourier transform.
We get the eigenvalues.
We're diagonalizing the
matrix, the convolution
becomes a multiplication,
and the solution becomes,
inversion becomes division.
I hope you see that.
That's really a model
problem for this course.
OK. yeah.
Questions.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] PROFESSOR
STRANG: Would I give you a six
by six Fourier matrix on a test?
Probably not.
No.
I just about could.
I mean, it's, six by six, those
are pretty decent numbers.
Right.
Those six roots of
unity, but not quite.
Right, yeah.
Yeah.
So four by four is, five by five
would not be nice, certainly.
Who knows the cosine
of 72 degrees?
Crazy.
But, 60 degrees we could do.
So the Fourier matrix would
be full of square roots
of three over two, and one
over two, and i's, and so on.
But it wouldn't be as nice,
so really four by four
is sort of the model.
Yeah, yeah.
So four by four is that model.
Other questions?
Because this is
really a key example.
Yeah.
When I calculated the
eigenvalues, yeah.
Ah.
Because this matrix, I know
everything about that matrix
when I know its first vector.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Yeah, it's because it's
a circulant matrix.
It's because that matrix
is expressing convolution
with this vector.
[2, -1, 0,  -1].
That circulant
matrix essentially
is built from four
numbers, right.
Yeah.
Yeah, and they go in
the zeroth column.
Right, yeah.
Yeah.
Right, so there is an
example where we could like
do everything.
Now, and let me just remember
that with this example,
we could do everything.
So this is an example of, you
could say this type of problem.
But with a very special kernel
there, so it turned out to be,
it looks like an
integral equation here
but if that kernel involves
delta functions and so on then
it can be just a
differential equation.
And then that's
what we got there.
So we took all-- The same
steps we did here, we did here.
We took the Fourier transform,
and I emphasize there,
just to remember Wednesday,
this was a delta function.
When I took the Fourier
transform I got a one,
so this was a one over this.
And I did the inverse transform
and I got back to the function
that I drew.
Which was e^(-ax) over 2a.
And even.
So, yeah. this was
the answer u(x).
So I was able to do that,
I mean this step was easy,
that step is easy.
That step is easy,
the division is easy.
And then I just recognize this
as the transform of this one,
this example that we had done.
Once I divided by 2a.
So you should be
able to do this.
So those are two that you
should really be able to do.
I'm not going to,
obviously I'm not going to,
ask you a 2-D problem on the
exam or even on a homework.
But now if you'll
allow me, I'd like
to spend a few minutes to
get into 2-D. Because really,
you've got the
main thoughts here.
That Fourier is
the same as finding
eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
That's the main thought
for these LTI problems.
OK, now suppose I have, let's
just get the formalities
straight here.
Suppose I have a
function of x and y.
2pi periodic in x, and in y.
So if I bump x by 2pi, or
if I bump y by 2pi -- oh,
I'm using capital F
for the periodic guys.
So let me stay with
capital F -- x, y+2pi.
OK, so I have a function.
This is given.
This is, it's in 2-D now.
And I want to write
its Fourier series.
So I'm just asking
the question what
does the Fourier series look
like for a function of two
variables.
The point is, it's going
to be a nice answer.
And so everything, what you
know how to do in 1-D you can do
in 2-D. So let me write the
complex form, the e^(ik) stuff.
So what would I write,
how would I write this?
I would write that as
a sum, but it'll have,
I'll make it a double sum,
I'll write two sigmas just
to emphasize that we're summing
from k equal minus infinity
to infinity, and from l equal
minus infinity to infinity.
We have coefficients c_kl.
They depend on two indices,
this is the pattern to know.
Multiplying our e^(ikx),
and our e^(ily).
Right, good.
So, alright.
Let me ask you.
How would I find c_23?
Just to know that-- We could
find all these coefficients,
find formulas for them.
We could do examples.
How would I find c_23?
So this is my F. I know
F. I want to find c_23.
What's the magic trick?
And I'm 2pi periodic, so all
integrals, all the integrals--
And I'm giving you
a hint, of course.
I'm going to integrate.
And the integrals will
all go from minus pi to pi
in x and in y.
They'll integrate over
the period square.
Here's the period
square from, there's
the center. x direction, y
direction, goes out to pi
and goes up to pi.
So all integrals
will be over dxdy.
But what do I integrate?
To find c_23.
Well, these guys are orthogonal.
That's what's making
everything work,
they're orthogonal
and very special.
So that by use
orthogonality, what do I do?
I multiply by?
Just tell me what
to multiply by.
By this and integrate.
OK, what is it that I multiply
by if I'm shooting for c_23,
for example? e^(i2x),
is it e^(i2x)?
Minus, right.
I multiply by e^(-i2x),
e^(-i3y), and integrate.
Yeah.
So when I multiply by
that and integrate,
everything will go
except the c_23 term.
Which will be
multiplied by what?
So I'll just have c_23
times probably 2pi squared.
I guess 2pi will come
in from both integrals,
so the formula will be
c_kl-- c_kl will be,
do you want me to
write this formula?
I'll write it here and
then forget it right away.
c_kl will be one
over 2pi squared,
the integral of my
function times my e^(-ikx),
times my e^(-ily) dxdy.
So that just makes the point.
That there's nothing new here,
it's just up a dimension.
But the formulas
all look the same,
and if F was a-- Well, if F is
a delta function, if F is now
a 2-D delta function.
We haven't done delta
functions in 2-D, why don't we?
Suppose F is the delta
function in 2-D. Then
what are the coefficients?
What do you think
you this means,
this delta function in 2-D?
So if I put in the delta
here, and I integrate.
And what do I get then?
So if this guy is a delta, a
two-dimensional delta function,
the rule is that
when I integrate over
a region that includes
the spike, so it's a spike
sitting up above a plane now,
instead of sitting above a line
it's sitting above a plane.
Then I get the value, so
this is the delta function
at the origin.
So I get the value of
this at the origin.
So what answer do I get?
I get one out of the
integral and then
I just have this constant.
So it's constant again.
And it's just one.
So the Fourier coefficients
of the delta function
are constant.
All frequencies
there are the same.
What about a line
of delta functions?
And what does that mean?
What about, yeah let me
try to draw delta(x).
Suppose I have a
function of x and y --
it's just worth imagining
a line of delta functions.
So I'm in the xy-- Let me
look again at this thing.
I have delta functions
all along this line.
Now.
Here is a crazy example,
just to say well there
is something new in 2-D. So
previously my delta function
was just at that point.
And the old integrals
just picked out
the value at that point.
But now think of
a delta function's
a sort of line of spikes.
Going up here, and then
of course it's periodic.
Everything's periodic
so that line continues
and this line appears here,
and this line appears here.
But I only have to focus
on one period square.
What's my answer now?
If this function suddenly
changes from a one-point delta
function to a line
of delta functions?
Now tell me what the
coefficients are.
What are the
Fourier coefficients
in 2-D for a line
of delta functions?
A straight line of delta
functions going up the y axis?
It'll be-- Let's see.
What do I do?
I'm go to integrate--
Oh yeah, what is it?
Good question.
OK.
So what is the--
When do I get zero
and when do I not
get zero out of this?
Yeah, tell me first when do I
get zero out of this integral?
And when do I not?
What am I doing here?
Help me.
I said 2-D was easy and I've
got in over my head here.
So look.
I can do the x integral, right?
We all know how to
do the x integral.
Yes, is that right?
If I integrate with respect
to x, what do I get?
Let's see, I'll keep that
one over 2pi squared.
Now I'm trying to
do this integral.
Do I get a one?
If I get a one from
the x integral.
So then I'm down
to one integral,
just the y integral is
left. e^(-ily) dy, right?
I did the x part, which said,
OK, take the value at x=0,
which was one.
So the x integral was one, good.
And now I've got
down to this part.
Now what is that integral?
It's two-- wait a minute.
Depends on l, doesn't it?
When l-- Yeah, so it's going
to depend on whether l is zero
or not.
Is that right?
Yeah, that's sort
of interesting.
If l is zero, then I'm
getting -- then this is a 2pi.
So the answer, so
I'm getting c_k0,
when l is zero I'm
getting a 2pi out of that.
If l is zero, I'm
integrating one,
I get a 2pi, cancels
one of those.
I get a one over 2pi.
And otherwise the other c_kl's,
when l is not zero, are what?
Just zero, I think.
The integral of this thing,
this is a periodic guy,
if I integrate it from
minus pi to pi it's zero.
What am I-- I'm making a
big deal out of something
that shouldn't be a big deal.
The delta(x) function,
this is just,
its Fourier series is
just the one we know.
Sum of e^(ikx)'s.
Do you see what's happened here?
It was supposed to
be a double sum.
But the ones, when l
wasn't zero, aren't there.
The only ones-- Yeah.
So I'm back to the, for a line
of spikes, a line of deltas,
I'm back to-- So
it only depended
on x, so the Fourier series is
just the one I already know.
All ones.
When there's no--
When l is zero,
all ones or 1/(2pi)'s, all
constants when l is zero,
but there's no y-- There's no
oscillation in the y direction.
OK, I don't know why I
got into that example,
because the conclusion was
just it's the Fourier series
that we already know and
it doesn't depend on l,
because the function
didn't depend on y.
OK, then we could
imagine delta functions
in other positions,
or a general function.
OK, so that's 2-D. Would I
want to tackle a 2-D-- Ha,
we've got two minutes. that's
one dimension a minute.
Right, OK.
What happens, what's a
2-D discrete convolution?
What's a 2-D
discrete convolution?
Now, you might say OK, why
is Professor Strang inventing
these problems?
Because a 2-D
discrete convolution
is the core idea of
image processing.
If I have an image, what
does image processing do?
Image processing
takes my image, it
separates it into
pixels, right, that's
all the image is,
bunch of pixels.
Then many 2-D image
processing algorithms,
will take-- JPEG,
old JPEG for example,
would take an eight by
eight, eight by eight 2-D,
in other words--
Eight by eight, 2-D
is the main point,
set of pixels.
And transform it.
Do a 2-D transform.
So what is a 2-D transform?
What would be the 2-D transform
that would correspond to this?
First of all how
big's the matrix?
Just so we get an idea.
I probably won't get to
the end of this example.
But just, so in 1-D, my
matrix was four by four.
Now I've got, so that was
for four points on a line.
Now I've got a square of points.
So how big is my matrix?
16, right?
16 by 16, because it's
operating on 16 pixels.
It's operating on 16
pixels, where in 1-D it only
had four to act on.
So I'm going to end up with
a 16 by 16 matrix here.
And I think-- Let me
see, what do I need?
Oh, wait a minute.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, I think the
time's up here.
Yeah, because my C, has my
C got to have 16 components?
Yes.
My u has to have 16,
my right-hand side
has got these 16 components.
Yeah.
So I'm up to 16 but a
very special circulant
of a circulant.
It'll be a circulant
of a circulant somehow.
OK, enough for 2-D.
I'll see you Wednesday
and we're back to reality.
OK.